JD already went back to the bullpen  there and yelled at the people quiet I  wish we had that on tape what do you  actually yell at everyone if I have to I  listen I push people before what I push  people before for the arch people hush  hush city punch be here  he's got overboard I don't know I'm  driving a jungle Manor taught for over  400 God pound what happened when I told  you I want quiet today because they have  to sleep for The Tonight Show you you  like went back in lecture then my man  you laughed you know what you should  have told them JD they should be as  quiet as they were when the CBS cameras  were in there yeah oh you couldn't hear  me good good for you dude thank you you  got my back see I heard that like JD is  so non-intimidating people just laughed  at hey Jason help him out Jason you take  over the job if he can't do it you dudes  if I drop dead from this [ __ ] book  promotion you're out of work you know  thanks